Consciousness is not there Consciousness
is not a personal self it's not a soul
it's phenomenal States it has a a
precise definition by totally and
utterly disagree with you good
all right this is one highly anticipated
episode today we have a theolocution
with Susan Blackmore and Bernardo Castro
well what is a theologution it's a
conversation between two people who are
trying to understand one another's views
and even constructively that is add to
the so-called opponent's views in real
time rather than destructively
criticizing with snark and even prepared
lines which is what unfortunately tends
to characterize most Clashing of ideas
so you can think of a theologution as a
Socratic dialogue that's moderated with
regard appreciation and fondness
Bernardo Castro is a leading voice in
the field of philosophy of mind he's
also a strong advocate of what's called
analytic idealism Bernardo argues that
Consciousness is fundamental in nature a
Viewpoint which is articulated in this
probative works including why
materialism is baloney and the idea of
the world links to both books are in the
description as well as links to
everything as usual because of the
contrasting views in my opinion this epi
episode serves as the best at least the
one that I've seen the best introduction
to bernardo's ideas although this is
only the case when one already has an
overview of some of the theories of
Consciousness that exist else you'll
just be weltering and swimming now Susan
Blackmore is a visiting professor at the
University of Plymouth who's carved out
a career in the study of Consciousness
memes and evolutionary biology becoming
one of the most influential voices in
these domains Susan is widely recognized
for her seminal work the meme machine in
fact years ago I read that and that's
how I was introduced to her work again
links to everything that's mentioned
will be in the description pertinent to
today's discussion Susan's an avid
proponent of illusionism which is more
nuanced than simply positing that
Consciousness is nothing more than some
Grand Illusion we talk about that and
she dispels this myth my name is Kurt
chemungal and I have this podcast here
called theories of everything where I
use my background in math and physics to
analyze toes from a theoretical physics
perspective predominantly though I'm
also interested in other approaches as
to what is fundamental what's considered
fundamental is there holism and
reductionism is incorrect how about
Consciousness and where does that come
into play you can think of it as the
largest Mysteries of the universe
without already having a defined
position that I'm advocating for or
trying to in a contrived way steer the
conversation toward at around 20 to the
30 minute Mark or so there'll be a
couple of ads this video is sponsored by
raid Shadow Legends alright now let's
picture this you got yourself a phone a
new phone and you're looking for an
adventurous mobile game to play Enter
raid Shadow Legends with its fantastic
visuals a menagerie of powerful
Champions challenging PVE bosses and
tactical PVP content many of you may
know I love video games so let me tell
you about the three most interesting
aspects of raid Shadow Legends in my
opinion firstly raid call of the Arbiter
is in full swing introducing new
characters like artak the orc Lord log
into raid for seven days before July
24th to get art back for free if you
haven't watched call of the Arbiter give
it a shot secondly rage Shadow Legends
visuals are breathtaking especially for
a mobile game with intricate scenes and
character designs immersing you in this
fantastic World thirdly raid's variety
of Champions and unique abilities offer
numerous strategic options for instance
the character Roy excels in Boss
fighting so new players if you haven't
started playing yet I urge you to also
enjoy this gameplay use my link which is
on screen now as well as the QR code you
can scan that and you'll get a free
starter pack with tremendous in-game
loot just hit the toe Link in the
description and I'll see you on the
battlefield those drastically help
support toe as well as the patrons and
if you'd like to support toe yourself
then visit patreon.com
kurtjimungle that's
c-u-r-t-j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l as a donation
with whatever you like genuinely helps
it helps not only financially it helps
emotionally to know that there are
people out there like yourself who
support to bring this to everyone at
zero cost like that's fantastic so thank
you to the patrons another podcast
that's coming up is a Theo location with
Bernardo Castro and David Papineau I
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly you
can look up they've had a conversation
before on YouTube so watch that and if
you feel like there was plenty that was
left out of that then feel free to
comment here and I'll ask those
questions to Bernardo and to David
bernardo's appeared several times on the
theories of everything channel one solo
Behemoth four hour episode that is
actually one of the top episodes on
theories of everything another one with
John vervakie in fact there are two
parts to that conversation definitely
don't miss the second one as you can see
a convergence of their ideas another one
with Christopher Langan another one with
Donald Hoffman as well as Susan
Schneider and another one with Sabine
hassenfelder on super determinism this
is Susan's First and definitely not the
last time on this channel enjoy welcome
Sue Susan Blackmore welcome Bernardo
Castro again it's a privilege to be here
with you all
good to see you both again
hello first time for me
sue you may not know this but I've
wanted to speak to you for years
primarily on memes because I read your
book on memes the first question is that
I'm sure people misconstrue what
illusionism is so do you mind rectifying
that so that we all have a shared
understanding as to what your
understanding of illusionism is
right well illusionism roughly speaking
is
um to say that what we normally think
about Consciousness all the assumptions
we make we're wrong we're deluded about
the nature of consciousness
there are lots of ways you can go with
it so more formally the idea is this so
the problem of Consciousness is
basically the mind-body problem How can
there be my experience of looking at at
um Kurt on the screen and the color of
his skin and the walls and the chair
behind and all this experience as well
as neurons that in some way are related
to that now I'm being very cautious
there and saying related to that because
then
um in 1994
um the the term the hard problem was
invented and that that is
um Dave Chalmers uh describes that as
the problem or the question of how
subjective experience arises from uh
brain activity
now as soon as you say that you're
falling into some kind of dualism and he
and and he himself Dave is is a kind of
dualist a very subtle sort of dualist
but the idea of illusionism is that's
the wrong problem we're so deluded that
we imagine Consciousness is something
that arises from brain activity but that
just simply doesn't work and that's why
we've not got anywhere in in
Consciousness studies with with really
trying to solve the hard problem if it's
the wrong the wrong problem what is the
right problem it is the illusion problem
in other words or otherwise known as The
Meta problem of Consciousness it is to
understand how we got so deluded how we
have invented all these Illusions about
the nature of Consciousness and we're
wrong so illusionism is is a kind of way
of approaching the problem of
Consciousness it's not a theory
to kind of line up against Global
workspace or IIT or whatever it is a way
of approaching it that says we won't get
anywhere unless we've understood how we
got into this model in the first place
so illusionists have a go at describing
the illusions
does that help yeah well before Bernardo
comes in I constantly hear that hey if
Consciousness is an illusion and this
may be one of those misinterpretations
but people would say Well it to The
Illusionist if Consciousness is an
illusion who is the illusion occurring
to so then what is your response to that
and then Bernardo please you'll be able
to comment on whatever you would like to
well the the the whom it's two
um is all part of the illusion because
um if you think of it this way um what
is a self if the natural way to imagine
what a self is or who am I am
is to imagine what dandenic calls the
Cartesian theater that is you imagine
and it's I think most of us are like
that most of the time a lot of
meditation you know I've been meditating
for more than 40 years and it blows
apart it to some extent
um maybe eventually completely
um this illusion that I'm sitting inside
my head I'm looking out through my eyes
to see the world I'm listening through
my ears to hear the world and I am in
control I have a stream of conscious
experience and I have free will which
enables me to you know manipulate myself
and the world or this body and the world
so this false idea of the self goes
along with illusionism so who is being
deluded well the whole thing is is a
delusion the whole thing is a
representation
constructed by information processing
system will get set me right on this I'm
sure
um the whole thing is an illusion about
self and other the separation of me and
other people the separation of me and
the world and that gives rise to all
these false ideas about the nature of
consciousness
okay Bernardo what is it you agree with
and do you perhaps disagree with and
perhaps just want to comment on no there
are a lot of things that I agree with
including the illusion of the person of
self I think there is no personal self
it's just not there at all
um the illusion of dualism I don't think
there are two things uh material brain
and phenomenal states that are generated
by the material brain
um but for the position of illusionism
to have use it it has to be specific and
and when you get people talking
specifically about it like lately Keith
Frankish Frankish has been talking about
it rather specifically then it has
become has talked specifically about it
for quite a while
the claim is that the way illusionism
circumvents the hard problem is by
saying that the nominal States or
experiential qualities do not exist that
they are illusions
but then the problem is illusionism is
then either coherent
or it is useless
um it is useless if we say
um
phenomenal States aren't what they seem
that's why they are an illusion
this is coherent but it's useless
because it doesn't do anything about the
heart problem of Consciousness because
the seaming is already a phenomenal
state
that there is an illusion an illusion is
a phenomenal State an illusion in so far
as it is experienced and if it's not
experienced it's not an illusion it's
already an instance of that which one is
trying to get rid of
now
illusionism would be useful if it said
phenomenal states are an illusion in the
sense that they don't really exist they
are edited digests of neuronal processes
and that's why our experiences don't
look like neurons firings and this is
Danny Dennis by the way because our
experience is an edited digest of the
neuronal firings
now this is incoherent because there is
an obvious infinite regress and it goes
as follows
what is that and its digest well it can
only be neuronal processes because for
The Illusionist there is nothing but
neuronal processes so the edit digest of
neuronal processes are themselves
neuronal processes
so why doesn't the edit digest look like
well because then you have a meta edit
Digest
but that too can only be neuronal
processes so you need a Meta Meta added
digest and you fall into Infinite
regress
so my position is illusionism has to be
made specific otherwise we are just we
can talk about anything I'm an
Illusionist I think the personal self is
an illusion but like Antonio damasio
claims and I think he is writing that
claim the problems that he conflates
that with the claim that Consciousness
is not there Consciousness is not a
personal self it's not a soul it's
phenomenal States it has a a precise
definition so you have to make it
specific and the moment you make it
specific it's either relevant or it's
incoherent
I totally and utterly disagree with you
the one thing that you that I do pick up
on that I should have said myself was
look at illusion
um in the dictionary because what
happened was Dan Dennett and I
frequently used to get accused of saying
Consciousness doesn't exist I'm like
what look you know ah
experience
some dictionaries and looked up illusion
and and as you described it it means
something that is not what it seems to
be and that is all illusionism is saying
now illusionism is not claiming as I
said before it's not claiming to be
specific it's not claiming to be a
theory that can be tested against other
theories like IIT or higher order
thoughts or you know all the other
theories of Consciousness it's an
approach that says we've got it so badly
wrong we need to start again from the
beginning now one way to start again
might be to idealism well I'm sure come
on to that it wouldn't be the way that I
go but there may be other ways to go but
you said unless it's specific it can't
solve the hard problem but it's not
trying to solve the hard problem it's
trying to say look the hard problem is
completely wrong because it's deal is
from the start and it asks us to solve a
problem that doesn't really exist what
we need to do is work out
just how how we are imagining our
Consciousness to be and see why that
happened now you talked about you said
something like an Illusionist says
subjective states don't exist well I I
mean the thing is illusionism is not one
Theory so there are lots of us doing
different things thinking in different
ways but I wouldn't say that subjective
states don't exist I mean as long as
there is a subject I.E a
self-construction a mental model a
representation of a self and there seems
to be a world out there then that's a
subjective state
but it's not in my mind something that
the brain generates
um I mean the brain is constructing
representations and so maybe we need to
ask well why is there something it's
like to be a representation and then you
think well a representation says telling
you what it's like isn't it it's a
representation of that tree and that you
know whatever
um so I I think you're I I can
understand what you're saying about it
needs to be precise but I I and it isn't
because it isn't claiming to be it's not
useless because it will help us I
believe to see through the problems of
the other theories which are not solving
that all the other theories claim to be
approaching at least to the hard problem
and illusionism doesn't and I think in
that sense in a very small way I'm not
claiming a huge amount for it really
um but I think it's the way forward to
go to work out why and how the illusion
appears Illusions illusions of self of
Consciousness and free will all of them
what is illusionism for you if you can
be precise I mean that there are
Illusions going on it's trivial of
course there are the the Consciousness
may not be what it seems it's trivial of
course there are many things we think we
experience but actually it's something
else going on so what is this the the
philosophical metaphysical relevance of
the illusionism and how do you specify
precisely what the claim is because so
far you you just hand waved around the
dictionary meaning of the word
illusionism so so what is the
illusionism illusionism specifically
well for me it is
I I can't say any more than I've I've
really said because I don't know where
it's going I play around with all sorts
of possible solutions I mean I've
thought a lot about idealism I've
thought about a lot about different
kinds of pan psychism I've thought about
all sorts of other things that maybe if
we can see through the Illusions
um we will understand how that works now
I would say this if I look around at
this world now
um there seems to be a self and a world
there isn't something else I mean a
materialist will say well that you know
ultimately there's some ultimate
underlying whatever it is
um uh with the forces of nature and
whatever and this is arising from that
and there is a sort of natural
separation between
um experience and the world that we're
experiencing that seems to me that's
part of what the illusion is and how do
we get by that it seems to me that
that's what you're trying to do is is to
get past that
I don't have an answer so I mean you're
you're both going to be really
frustrated with me because I'm not going
to say that I have an answer that to set
against your answer I'm just saying that
we're so deeply confused we have to
throw out an awful lot and and start
again I'm sorry if that is not you know
not enough it's not enough meat if you
like but it's very interesting um we've
both mentioned Dennett I mean back in
1991 in Consciousness explained the book
that so many people say should be called
Consciousness explained away that means
they haven't got what he's trying to do
at all that book was full of uh traps
that you can fall into the Cartesian
theater I mentioned is just one of them
but for example there's a very very
common idea in most of Consciousness
studies a lot of the research
um which is that some processes in the
brain are conscious and some other
processes in the brain are not conscious
now what on Earth could this mean
um do some have qualier attached
um and some don't to some sort of
magically
um
it it you know uh give rise to ex
produce
um something called experience
um uh or colors or or any kind of
experience it it doesn't really make any
sense that's just one of them but that
whole thing has led to this search for
the neural correlates of Consciousness
now I think as an Illusionist
that that is one of the things that
illusionism helps you to see and that
danit's work has helped me to see
um that that is a false distinction
there there are not conscious and
unconscious processes on the brain it's
a category mistake if you like
so those are the kind of things that I
find helpful in digging down and digging
down into the problem and hoping that
something will become clearer than it is
now
and it's not to deny that there's
experience that's what we're trying to
struggle with
Sue briefly are you a materialist or you
don't subscribe to that no I'm not a
materialist because I'm probably for
probably the same reasons as Bernardo
um it doesn't work I mean it it gives
rise to the hard problem which is to my
mind an idiot problem it's you know it
doesn't make sense to say that that
experience arises from brain processes
either it's got to be brain processes in
some way or we've got to have some other
kind of theory
um does that kind of answer sure
Bernardo
um
I think the last comment you made is is
almost ends the debate we can now just
Converse
um it's a lot sorry I didn't I didn't
the last comment you made that
materialism doesn't work because of the
heart problem it sort of ends the debate
we can now just I'm not saying
naturalism doesn't work that's a
different statement isn't it naturalism
is not the same as materialism I said
materialism oh sorry sorry I am a
naturalist too right fine
um I didn't mean when I asked the
question that you'd be more specific I
didn't mean to to ask you to give me a
metaphysical Theory and let alone a
complete one
um I asked you to specify the hypothesis
you are defending because I can only
agree or disagree if I know what it is
that you are defending what it is that
your position is
um but as you just said what you call
illusionism is not what
the vast majority at least of
philosophers out there writing about
illusionism consider illusionism to be
the the relevance of illusionism in
philosophy today is the attempt to deny
the existence of phenomenal states of
experiential States
because I'm not a philosopher I know
more about psychologists than than
philosophers but who is saying that that
these states don't exist uh Keith
Frankish says that there is an important
sense in which experiential states do
not have phenomenal properties that's
what he says they do not have phenomenal
properties as in descriptions of qualia
he doesn't say they don't exist the
nominal states are phenomenal properties
if states do not have phenomenal
properties they are not phenomenal
states that you cannot argue out of it
and microgracia you ask me for examples
so I'm giving you examples let me answer
Michael graciano is on record saying
Consciousness does not exist it's
something that doesn't happen so that's
what is being peddled out there and
Keith is is quite explicit he although
he dances an impossible dance because
what he says is that
we think we have phenomenal States when
we introspect
because everything happens as though we
had phenomenal States
but we don't
the problem is that the nominal states
are the only instance of something that
the seeming of it is already it the
illusion of it is already it and after
he goes through a tortuous conceptual
acrobatic acrobatics he says but yes we
don't have the answer yet for how
non-phenomenal states can represent
phenomenal States well that's the only
question that matters that's the
question that started the whole thing so
if you ask me Susan I think illusionism
is a show in philosophy it's just a
bunch of vague hand-waving conceptual
acrobatics and contortions that only
postpone the problem and hide it behind
an absolute absolute lack of clarity of
thinking now all materialism it's the
only game in town because given the hard
problem of Consciousness the
irreducibility of qualities to to
quantitative parameters you have to find
a way to argue that phenomenal States in
a very significant sense are not there
so you end up dancing this dance in
which people say well of course there
are subjective States we can't deny that
and then they proceed to argue that
there aren't subjective States
what the hell is this that's why I keep
asking you to be specific and precise
because illusionism is now so slippery
that whatever you think it is it is and
you argue against that the Defenders
will say well that's not what I mean
what is it that what the hell then is it
that you mean and my my conclusion is
what I said from the beginning it is
either useful or it is coherent it
doesn't go both ways now I understand
that what you consider to be illusionism
is a a much less specific thing you are
just focused on the dictionary meaning
of the word illusion and you're saying
well there are Illusions yes there are
Illusions and seeing through them can
help us yes saying through our Illusions
can help us but it's almost the issue
you see it's it's completely true it
says nothing it's not doing anything
when you talk about Illusions like that
you seem to be talking and earlier as
well about
um
perception reality kind of errors and
this isn't like that this is this is
having an illusion about the whole
nature of every moment of experience
that we have
um going back to Frankish
um in that uh book that special issue of
Journal of Consciousness studies you may
see that in the beginning of my piece I
dissociate from his idea that
um that experiences don't have the
states don't have phenomenal properties
because I I can't go along with him on
that and so in a way I'm weaker in my
argument but
um and you can criticize me for that but
I still think it's essential for us to
tackle the current theories all of which
fall into these kind of traps I mean I
talk about one of them and the whole
hunt for the neural correlates of
Consciousness again and again people are
falling into the traps that then it laid
out
but you mentioned Michael Graziano
um and it's very interesting that he
refuses to be called an Illusionist now
he's probably being quite canny here and
it may pay off because people don't like
the word illusionism and he doesn't want
to be associated with it but I think his
theory is absolutely a version of
illusionism and I think it's the best
theory we've got at the moment although
it doesn't solve all the problems but he
is basically saying
um just as we have a body schemer so so
his theory for anyone listening is
attention
um attentional schema Theory now uh the
idea of a schema is quite important I'm
particularly interested in the body
schema which you use to compare with it
so all the time our body are break the
whole nervous system is constructing
um our model or representation of where
our body is and what it's doing this is
called the body schema I'm particularly
interested in this because we now know
that this is what goes awry in an
out-of-body experience and I've done a
lot of work on upper body and near-death
experiences and so on so I'm very
familiar with that idea now the idea of
an attention schema is that any
um complex information processing system
has a divert energy of resources to
different things all over the place and
we call this attention in in humans and
other animals and that
um experience at any time is what is
represented in the attention schema now
this is an interesting way of going
about it because it's not having an
outside world with objects that then
have to have properties that we to have
phenomenal properties because we're
looking at an object it's it's mapping
or representing the attention schema
instead now whether this gets us
anywhere I don't know but I've spent
quite a lot of time playing around with
the idea of observing in different
states of Consciousness
um whether it feels like
um an attention schema and that's quite
fun I've been doing the same with um
predictive processing Theory and active
inference and so on which kind of does
slightly relate to it
um and this leads me to another thought
that I have which is
there's there are lots and lots of ways
of going about the the problem of
Consciousness but one of them for me is
through personal practice of mindfulness
meditation taking psychedelic drugs all
kinds of things that change one State of
Consciousness because I feel that that
approach is needed alongside the
scientific approach and the
philosophical approach oh you're nodding
there so I'd like to hear what you think
about that
oh yeah some of you are extremely famous
colleagues I think agree with you but I
I can't say anything more beyond that
um I I agree I think introspection is
one of the royal Avenues to knowledge
especially if you're talking about the
mind uh if one is doing Neuroscience of
Consciousness or philosophy of Mind
introspection is essential so the person
know what he's talking about I mean that
doesn't replace objective studies like
neuroimaging which I think is extremely
valuable it's been getting a lot of
flack recently justifiably to some
extent but I think it's a great advance
of the 21st century it doesn't replace
clinical experience but it's it's
certainly a key component back to
Graziano he's an Illusionist in in the
broad sense that you are using in the
sense that what he's trying to deny is
the existence of some kind of personal
soul
but I mean who would disagree with that
it's it I almost said you're still alive
on the planet today well who amongst the
people who are working seriously on this
would disagree with that so I almost
yawn at that
um
um he would go he's considered an
eliminativist as opposed to an
Illusionist because illusionism is the
denial not of it is invited so but the
denial of phenomenal States and that's
not how you are using the word because
you just said you acknowledge the
existence of phenomenal States so
strictly speaking from a philosophical
perspective you aren't an Illusionist so
you I'm not the real thing you are
you're an illusion of one and and if you
if you are not a dualist which it seems
you are not and you want knowledge the
existence of phenomenal States then you
are pair Force an idealist semantically
there is no other space for you to land
if you know what I mean what about
um pan psychism
I'm not particularly Landing there but
I'd love to hear what you think about
that because that's the idealism isn't
the only possibility is it
well you just said it was maybe you
could defend that
there are versions of pen psychism that
would that would State the following the
nominal states are not just extra
properties of subatomic particles they
are the essence of subatomic particles
and all the other properties like Mass
charge momentums being these are all
external appearances of that Essence and
that comes down to a form of uh
live it's not like idealism a monad like
Theory
um but that's physically incoherent and
and it amazes me that this stuff is
still talked about because we have known
things at least the 1940s at least since
1949 when Feynman published his famous
Quantum electrodynamics paper with the
defining diagrams and all that stuff
that cotton Nobel Prize we've known
since then that particles are just
metaphors for local excitations of
underlying feuds in other words there
are no particles there's nothing to a
particle but they're underlying field
just as there is nothing to a ripple but
the underlying Lake you can't fish the
Ripple out of the lake because the
Ripple is a doing of the lake it's not a
thing it's a behavior particles are the
same thing particles are behaviors of
underlying Quantum fields and without
this we couldn't begin to make sense of
a great many things we know happen for
instance we couldn't make sense of
particle Decay a Higgs boson can Decay
into two quarks
or or two mules which are heavy
electrons but there aren't two melons in
the hex Boson
so how how does it become Two Mules well
it's because decaying means that a
particular excitation in the underlying
field in this case the the Higgs field
uh decays one Ripple becomes two other
ripples there is no magic in that but if
you think particles are things then the
Heats both magically disappears and two
muons magically appear it's like what
the hell but I I don't even need to get
to to go that far we wouldn't be able to
explain particle interactions
which is something quantum theory
doesn't give us only Quantum Feud Theory
so there are no particles and psychism
assumes that there are particles with
delineated spatial boundaries and that
they are
self-existing things now this is
physically contradictory it doesn't even
well that's only one version of pants
I'm not going to defend pan psychism but
I I do enjoy playing around with it but
there are lots of other forms that say
um uh only living things can be
conscious or uh only you know higher
order thinking things will be conscious
or I don't know different size objects
there's all sorts of variations or even
just representations
um maybe anything any system that
represents something uh as internal or
or external to itself
um could be
um have experience there's lots of
versions but what I got confused with
what you were saying was I thought you
were just talking about like knits and
then
um how physics and Feynman and so on
um but were you actually talking about
what you believe because what is this
underlying field if you are an idealist
um what do you mean by an underlying
field
deals under quantum theory are our
models we model nature in terms of
fields and fields are spatially
distributed they exist in every point of
space-time that's the model of a field
but everything in science is a
convenient fiction like when Newton
proposed this invisible force acting at
a distance instantaneously between the
Earth and the moon the force of gravity
that was a convenient fiction today it's
no longer convenient we know there is no
such Force gravity is a distortion of
space-time a bending of space-time
actually even that later convenient
fiction is now Falling by the wayside
because now with Quantum Loop gravity
that whole thing is being revised so we
shouldn't take the 17 Quantum fields
that exist today at real existence
because they are just conceptual models
that allow us to to predict the Nature's
Behavior now what it does tell us is
that whatever is going on it's not
spatially localized
the world is not made of little bricks
that are put together that's not how
nature Works
unless you make that step to Fields a
great many things would break you
wouldn't be able to reconcile
um quantum theory with relativity you
wouldn't be able to explain particle
interaction you wouldn't be able to
explain particle Decay you wouldn't be
able to explain the quantum foam or
spontaneous Quantum excitations and
therefore you wouldn't be able to
explain uh um what people call 0.4s
which is casimir's effect which is
experimental experimentally demonstrated
so what what these models are telling us
is that at the bottom level nature is
not spatially localized
that's the the bottle the bottleneck and
it dovetails nicely with idealism at
least with objective forms of idealism
which say yes there is a world out there
it's not in our minds it's not
susceptible to our fantasy Ro wishes or
our affirmations every morning it's
objective from our point of view and it
would it would still be there even if we
were not here but it too is mental in
nature just like my thoughts are
objective from your point of view even
if you are not there I would still be
having thoughts and whatever fantasy you
may entertain it doesn't affect my
thoughts from your point of view my
thoughts are objective but they are out
to there they are outside your personal
mind so the claim is there are mental
processes out there they are not ours
they are objective from our perspective
they are predictable that's why science
Works they are non-localized because
there is only one field of subjectivity
this is critical to avoid the
combination problem and itself nicely
with Feud Theory because the whole the
whole for the past 40 years the whole of
physics is trying to do the so-called
Grand unification Theory sort of folding
gravity into the quantum fields and
going from 17 to 1 and theory was an
attempt and now we have Loop quantum
gravity so it dovetails nicely with that
but forget idealism there are no
particles this is not my belief this is
not my opinion this is textbook Quantum
field Theory it's the basis of the
standard model it's what is guiding us
when we invest billions of dollars or
Euros at CERN this this is not even news
it some would claim we've known that
since 19 the 1920s but at least since
the 1940s
but I don't understand
um the fundamental lack of understanding
I have
is if if you take your idealist View and
you're saying that there is still the
fields
objectively existing why do they behave
the way they do I mean how do you get if
everything is is basically mind or
mental
I'm not sure whether you would say
everything is conscious but anyway if
everything is mental and that comes
first why do we get these apparent laws
of nature the way things behave um the
consistency why I mean at least
materialism has some kind of answers to
the way the world behaves or are you
saying it doesn't
um you know I I just think you shift
from one to the other you shift from
materialism to idealism I don't know
what you've what you've gained in in
doing that well you avoid the dualism
you avoid the hard part avoid dualism
yes absolutely we have to avoid dualism
and you avoid the heart problem of
Consciousness
the notion that something that is mental
in essence cannot behave regularly is
merely a metaphysical Prejudice human
Minds evolved in a planetary ecosystem
and therefore we evolved to be very
reactive and so you could say human
Minds which have developed higher level
mental functions and are reactive to
their environment they are difficult to
predict but although even human Minds
can be predicted and psychology is
making progress in that direction but a
mind without higher level mental
functions can behave according to
precise irregularities why because
that's what I want to understand why why
are there these regularities or laws or
or consistencies and so you say that you
know our mind
um it works in particular ways why does
it produce the appearance of a brain and
neurons and all of that kind of stuff
these are two questions so why does it
behave regularly because it is what it
is that nature clearly behaves regularly
I mean whatever metaphysics you have the
regularity of Nature's behavior is a
given we can predict what nature will do
next that's why technology Works
otherwise it wouldn't but the Prejudice
is that mind can't behave regularly well
the news is it does even if it's so
complex that it's difficult to predict
it does behave regularly and two we
cannot anthropomorphize that mind of
nature out there that can be a very
probably is a very simple mind didn't
evolve higher level mental functions in
a planetary ecosystem it's an
instinctive spontaneous mind and behaves
according to regularities
alligators have very regular Behavior if
you approach them and you cross a
certain threshold of distance they may
Lounge at you but if you don't cross
that threshold they never try to Lounge
at you Minds can be very predictable so
this is not an argument against idealism
now why does it seem the way way it does
now it's a technical answer to cut me if
you think it's going too far but there
are two reasons for this one is we
cannot see the world as it actually is
because there would be information
overload it's like seeing the files in
your computer on your desktop exactly
the way they are millions of open or
closed microscopic switches that's
useless it's not it doesn't favor
survival what you want is to perceive
the Salient features that are relevant
that's one answer the other answer is
entropy control if our intercognitive
states would mirror the states of the
world there would be no upper bound to
our internal entropy because there is no
a priori upper bounds to the entropy of
the world so if you were to mirror those
States in our inner cognitive states
without a bound to our internal entropy
and now using an illustrative metaphor
we could melt into hot meat soup because
on bounded entropy is not compatible
with structural and dynamic integrity
and this has been shown mathematically
by some neuroscientists so we see the
relevant and Salient information about
our environment at a glance and the
result of that is what we call the
colloquially physical world the contents
of the screen of perception that's much
more conducive to survival and to
maintaining our internal structural and
dynamic Integrity then seeing the states
of the world for what they actually are
to use another metaphor
the contents of the screen of perception
are like the dashboard of an airplane
the airplane has sensors it makes
measurements of the states of the sky
outside and those measurements are
presented to the pilot in the form of a
dashboard
and the pilot can fly based on the
dashboard alone flying by instruments
you don't need a transparent windscreen
to see the world as it actually is guess
what that's exactly what we do we have
sensors Eyes Ears tongs surface of the
skin we make measurements and those
measurements are presented to to meta
Consciousness which is different from
phenomenal States it's something that
comes on top is presented to meta
Consciousness in the form of the
physical world so the physical world is
an internal dashboard it does convey
accurate information about the real
world but it doesn't look like the real
world because not only does it not need
to a dashboard it doesn't look like the
clouds in the sky but because it
shouldn't in order to control our
internal entropy and and and facilitate
uh prompt reactions to environmental
challenges
we're all confused now because you're
talking about
um the way the world seems and how the
world really is and almost all of that
second part of your answer seems to me
could be spoken by a materialist and
make perfect sense and I don't see what
idealism gives you to help with that I
mean yes of course this is we I've
talked about attention and attention
schema Theory
um we have to pay attention to things
that matter to us we evolved
um in we evolved the skills that we have
and the minds that we have in order to
survive and get around in the
environment we are evolved in not to
have an accurate view of
um what is
um actually out there and now you're
talking about things that are actually
out there just as a materialist or as a
dualist would indeed so I'm deeply
confused now because I don't know what
idealism what difference idealism makes
and what it adds and how it helps us it
takes away a next foreignty category
that is completely unnecessary namely
something that is not mind something
that is not phenomenal something that is
not mental so you're recording all the
outside world there so we have our our
experiences of the world and so on and
the outside world there you're just
calling that conscious or mental
um rather than calling it something
completely different and physical but
what does that mean to say that it's
meant like that's what I just don't get
it means that it's of the same kind as
your own intermentation in other words
it's qualitative in nature it cannot be
exhaustively described in terms of a
list of numbers the latter is
materialism okay and by by avoiding this
non-mental stuff
you avoid having to come back from no
mental stuff to mental stuff which is
the hard problem of Consciousness you
avoid this all together so now you're
saying the world out there is made of
qualities these are not the qualities of
my perception these are different
qualities my perception is an internal
dashboard representation of the
qualities that are out there there are
actual qualities out there and they are
mental in some kind of nature that I
don't quite understand what that means
that they're mental
they are mentoring the sense that they
are experienced by Nature they are
experiential in essence but we don't
experience those qualities as they are
we have a representation of those
qualities so now we have to come from
qualities to real qualities that are out
there to the qualities of perception
that's a much easier Bridge because
there is no fundamental ontological
transition now you have mental states of
one kind modulating mental states of
another is this coherent of course it is
it's happening every time every day to
all all of us your thoughts modulate
your emotions your emotions modulate
your thoughts your thoughts modulate
your fantasies mental states of
different kinds are modulating one
another all the time in all of us said
something a bit contentious there
um
about
um thoughts and emotions
uh are you saying that the thoughts
cause the emotions or are you saying
that they are the same as the emotional
what what is what are you saying about
the relationship between thoughts and
emotions
they are both mental States so there is
no antic distinction between them but we
use different words because there is
something about it the respective
qualities that allow us to differentiate
one from the other
now if you have a certain emotion it
changes the kinds of thoughts you are
liable to having or if you have certain
kinds of thoughts you become more prone
to experiencing certain other emotions
so mental states can modulate other
mental States trivially it's happening
all the time that's how minds work so
all I'm saying now is that there are
external mental states that modulate our
internal
cognitive mental states there is no hard
problem anymore but there is still an
external world it's subjective from its
own point of view but objective from our
point of view
I think what why I'm why I'm bothered
about that was because I'm thinking
about the time course of thoughts versus
emotions and what causes what and so on
and I was imagining an emotion in terms
of all the
neurotransmitters and hormones and all
the other things that give rise to
bodily feelings and when you say that
thoughts affect bodily feelings there
appears to be a problem there but that's
the problem that you're getting away
with by saying that that they're all
mental things affecting each other in a
mental the whole world is mental stuff
and obviously that makes sense of mental
things affecting other mental things
yeah yeah and and then what are the
neurotransmitters what are the neuronal
firings the neurons and all this stuff
um there are obvious correlations
between this stuff and what we feel from
within denying those correlations just
silly it's just okay then you don't even
enter the Party If you deny that how can
we account for that under an idealist
perspective under idealism all matter
is a dashboard representation of a
mental state when observed from across a
dissociative boundary but they forget
about it again observed from
across a dissociative boundary because
we have to account for why can't can't I
read your thoughts why do I not know
what's happening in the galaxy of
Andromeda if it's all only one big mind
then why am I not enlightened right so
we have to account for that and the
account for that is dissociation which
is something that Psychiatry now managed
to show objectively with the Advent of
neuroimaging that it does happen and it
can literally make you blind so why
wouldn't it make you make your blind to
what's happening in the galaxy of
Andromeda or in the mind of another
person and then
the way it all comes together is
all matter under idealism is an inner
cognitive representation of external
mental States
when they are observed across a
dissociative boundary that's what matter
is now your neurons are made of the same
atoms and force fields that make up the
rest of the universe they are also
material so your neurons are what your
inner dissociated mental processes look
like when they are observed from across
a dissertative boundary your body is
what your dissociated implementation
looks like when it is observed from
across a dissociative boundary and
represented on a cognitive dashboard so
to say like the dashboard of an airplane
can you please give me the simplest
understanding of a dissociative boundary
I mean I'm sort of struggling with you
you're talking in a lot of different
ways there and I kind of think I got the
gist of it but then I'm thinking I
clearly haven't got this quite right
because there'll be dissociative
boundaries within the system and between
the system and other people and and so
on but I haven't quite
got to the bottom of what you mean what
would be a sort of minimal dissociative
boundary conceptually a dissociative
boundaries is what's given by
inferential isolation but then it gets
technical so instead of that I will
appeal to empirical studies and then it
makes it more and more alive
so um you may know this in 2015 there
was this woman a patient of dissociative
identity disorder in Germany and she had
many Alters or dissociated centers of
awareness two of these altars claimed to
be blind but the human the woman could
see perfectly well her eyes were okay
her visual cortex was okay her Optical
Optical nerves were okay there was
nothing wrong
um so neuroscientists had this fantastic
idea of instrumenting her with an EEG
cap and measuring her brain activity
both when the host personality had
executive control and when one of the
so-called blind Alters had executive
control lo and behold when one of those
altars had executive control the woman
would have no brain activity in the
visual cortex
but when the host personality would be
back even though that the woman's eyes
were open so she literally couldn't see
what was right in front of her eyes with
nothing physically wrong with her eyes
Association can do that when the host
personality would be back in executive
control there would be normal activity
in the visual cortex so dissociation
this is an extreme form of dissociation
it renders you literally blind to what's
in front of your open eyes but soft
forms of dissociation are happening to
us all the time when you forget
something that you know you know you're
dissociated when you park your
relationship relationship problems to be
able to go to work and perform
you are dissociated
um when you can't remember an old trauma
but dissociation does happen in degrees
now how what is the actual mechanism how
can we conceptualize that we are not
there yet but it obviously has to do
with inferential isolation which is what
happens when you can't remember
something you cannot follow a sort of
chain of cognitive Association but I
don't get how this kind of relates to
idealism I mean I can understand all of
that in terms of brain function and how
I mean I don't know the mechanism for
shutting down V1 but I do know by
playing around at the edges of sleep and
so on that I can manipulate whether I'm
I think whether what what I'm
experiencing is from V1 or is from from
a higher imaginary factors and if I
don't I don't I what I was getting at in
my question was
you you've talked about these
dissociative boundaries as though they
apply to the whole world not just to one
human being
um because the way you were talking was
like between a person and and the world
out there and I wondered can you really
um find these boundaries in
in the world as you're imagining it made
entirely of mental stuff what would kind
of be a minimal
um dissociative boundary that needs to
be crossed that's what I don't
understand about this okay first a brief
comment to really understand the
idealism we have to understand it under
its own terms not under materialist
terms or assumptions because otherwise
you'd just
um I think life okay let me give you
first another study in 2014 Yolanda
Chillum here in the Netherlands did the
study in which she took a group of
people diagnosed with the dissociative
identity disorder in a group of actors
and she put both groups under an fmri to
see if doctors could objectively
diagnose a dissociation and the actors
were asked to pretend to themselves that
they were dissociated lo and behold you
can objectively diagnose in other words
there is something dissociation looks
like
it looks like certain patterns of
identifiable patterns of brain activity
the association has an extrinsic
appearance an Outer Image it looks like
something so my claim is life biology is
what dissociation at a higher level
looks like
and that's why I can't read your
thoughts for as long as I am alive for
as long as I look like biology
metabolism that's what the dissociative
process in nature is looking like at
that level just like a person with the
idea has patterns of brain activity that
look like something identifiable so
that's what life is and that's why I
can't read your thoughts now your inner
mental processes within the boundaries
of that of your dissociation
they have to look like something if they
are observed from across the
dissociative boundary and lo and behold
they look like the neural correlates
what you're talking about yeah okay
uh I find this particularly interesting
when you keep talking about why I can't
um know your thoughts because I spent
the first sort of 20 years of my
research life looking for telepathy and
Clairvoyance and so on and never finding
them and it's still of great interest to
me because I spent a lot of time you
know if if all the it's all out there in
the akashic records as the theosophers
would would have it and all the
information is there then why can't I
get it and I had a great Theory
um when I was doing my PhD uh that
memory uh the only reason that we
remember our own thoughts and not
everybody else's is because they're more
similar and I I'm still attracted to
thoughts a lot you know ideas along that
that kind of stream so that was very
interesting to me but I'd like to pick
up on something else you said um because
you said it sounds absolutely
extraordinary that this um uh
person suffering from
um identity dissociation disorder
um
could look at something and not see it
but we can all look straight at
something and not see it and we can also
see something that we haven't looked
straight at
um I say this because it's something
that I often talk about in lectures I I
was at a conference on psychedelics last
weekend which was wonderful and I was
talking about illusionism there
um and I showed simple demonstrations
um the the classic one is of course the
gorillas in our midst video which I'm
sure you've seen
um and I won't say more for anyone who
hasn't seen it to spoil it but you know
you you you literally must be looking
straight at The Thing That You Don't See
but I also do a little trick which is
does the opposite thing
um in uh Consciousness explained
um Dan talked about a room papered
entirely with identical portraits of
Marilyn Monroe
um I just made up a picture of identical
portraits of Dan Dennis and there's 18
in this picture and uh you know how many
circades you can make in a second
probably five or six or something like
that and if you just show the picture to
people for two seconds you know they
cannot have looked at all the pictures
and yet what when you ask them what they
saw they say I saw 18 identical pictures
of dandeni and one with horns and a scar
so we've got one with haunts and a scar
on it and um
so then I can explain how you're using
texture detection straight line
detection all sorts of shortcuts to say
oh all those pictures are the same you
don't need to look at them all in order
to come to the conclusion and that
conclusion is what you see it's not what
went in your eyes it's what you will
report later that you saw
so it dissociates um you know you can
you can see what you haven't looked at
and you can look at what you haven't
seen this doesn't help with idealism and
all of that but I thought it's kind of
relevant too yeah you're making that it
is it it is I mean blindsight is a super
curious phenomenon as well there is a
paper by there are people
published in 2002
forgot the name of the altar I know him
personally it's because I take
amitriptyline for my tinnitus sometimes
I forget stuff we all love that stuff
it's a relief when someone else does go
on
I remember the the paper was called
dissociations between Consciousness and
matter Consciousness or something like
this so there are multiple mechanisms
involved
um in the case you you refer to that you
don't see the gorilla I bet that if you
had been instrumented with an EEG cap
although you don't report seeing the
gorilla there would be a visual cortex
activity so it's not the same as what
this German guys did with the woman with
the dissociative identity disorder but
it does reflect an important distinction
that we often don't make even in
academic discourse which is the
difference between phenomenal States
pure and simple experiences pure and
simple
and metacognitive phenomenal States
those require something more those
require not only the experience
but the explicit knowing that you are
having the experience and that's a
product of attention you need to attend
to become metacognitive of an experience
for instance we are always experiencing
our breathing now the inflation and
deflation of our rib cage the airflow in
our nafters but we are most of the time
not matter conscious of our breathing
because we don't put our attention there
we don't bring it under the focus of
attention so um the the Curious Thing is
that there can be almost permanent
dissociations between experience and
matter experience like Blindside where
people act as and react as though they
see something but they can't report it
and what I'm trying to drive to is that
there is never such a thing as states
that are not phenomenal there is never
such a thing as strictly unconscious
States even if you go back to the
history of psychology and how the word
unconsciousness came from Young Freud
and bsna and all the others what they
are describing and it's very clear when
you read their texts what they are
describing is meta consciousness they
are not describing experience they are
describing knowledge explicit
introspective knowledge of the
experience so what this tells us is that
we may never actually be unconscious we
know now that if you undergo syncope if
you pass out people report amazing stuff
During the period in which they were
understanding you talked about us being
conscious and that involves a self who
is so I can get the idea that the uh
these things that we call unconscious
are in some sense mental and then the
metacognitive is is is added on onto
that but that usually involves the the
feeling that I am now paying attention
to this and I am so on so it's all part
of the illusion so you could say that
illusionism at least in the way I'm
thinking of it is that all that
metacognitive stuff is is is
speculations that are untrue and
underlying that I don't know I it's just
you as a proper philosopher who have
thought through all this this idealism
stuff and you can talk about it
coherently I'm only getting as far as
saying all this stuff's wrong but what
is there when there's a processes going
on there's responses going on and
there's not somebody going ah this is
what I'm
um you know I'm doing this now that's
where the illusion comes in thinking
that what we have to explain is that not
we have to explain the whole underlying
thing and I come back again to personal
experience
um I tend not to call it introspection
because that has such historical
problems associated with it but that
that's what you call it and it's fair
enough all different kinds mindfulness
is a real nightmare because there's so
many different forms of it but one from
I've done a lot of practice intensive
practice of mindfulness in ordinary life
and what can happen is their whole
metacognitive thing disappears
and you there's there's stuff happening
um now if you're an ordinary life you
can't let go completely of the
metacognitive stuff you have to have
some kind of awareness of I'm walking
along here and whatever
um but in meditation you can let go of
it completely and then there seems to be
this is just I'm talking from personal
experience here in certain kinds of deep
meditation particularly on Retreat there
can be a sense in which there's stuff
happening but it's not happening to
anybody and it's not even happening in
time or space it's kind of lost all
those things
there's where I kind of go to try to
understand things and I don't get very
far and maybe and what you've been
telling me today I've got well not maybe
I have got more possible ways of
thinking about it
um I I'm not um completely buying it
because I don't understand you well
enough but I think we actually have some
commonality
in what I've just said there well by the
way I just remembered the name I had
forgotten Jonathan's cooler everybody
should know his name yeah so he
published this dissociations between
awareness and meta awareness back in
2002 a fantastic paper that I think
everybody should read I'm going to write
that out I'm doing something with him in
in the near future so that will be a
good thing
um
associations between Consciousness and
meta-consciousness or something like
this
2002.
um got it thank you
I
don't totally go along with your use of
the word illusionism and and I I don't
blame you for that or anything but I'm
not comfortable with it and the reason
is the following defined so
vaguely
the history of science is the history of
Illusion because hardly anything is what
it seems to be
I mean
you see the whole history of science is
a testament to that so if the word is so
broad that it encompasses so much it
becomes a useless word because we can't
specify something out of the background
uh by using it but don't forget all I'm
saying is consciousness is an illusion
and by that I guess what I mean is the
way people talk about Consciousness the
theories they build about Consciousness
the whole idea that Consciousness is
there's such a thing as Consciousness
itself which can be separated from you
know matter from unconscious States and
so on all of that's the problem I'm not
trying to say
um anything about the outside world on
physics and so on as being illusory I'm
simply talking about people's Concepts
matter whatever
um
Concepts about the nature of their own
minds and if you can clear away that
problem whether you do it by personal
practice or by some kind of theorizing
then I think we might be making progress
that's as far as I go really which is
pathetic I mean I you know I
I I would I don't blame you in the least
for saying well you know it's so it's
too vague and so on but I just feel it
it has to be done because I get so
frustrated with the theorists and the
experimenters and so on who constantly
refer to Consciousness as though it's
something produced by the brain and
that's the heart of what I'm trying to
get away with if that helps at all I
sympathize
um completely so I don't like the word
but I sympathize with it I I I'll give
you by the way I don't believe in a
personal self it's just not there it's a
narrative in a subject so every time I
say I I'm forced to say this by the
English language there are languages
that don't have that particular pronoun
but I don't speak them so I'm forced to
say which language Which languages uh
it's on some
it doesn't even have a written form I
think it's um we would call them
primitive languages although I hate this
word I think it's an inappropriate word
but there are languages in which there
is no first person pronoun so there are
some others in a simpler way which which
although they kind of infer it I mean I
I tried to learn polish once because my
first husband was polish and there isn't
they don't use the word iron in the same
heavy way that English uses it all the
time it's very often incorporated into
other words or it's such a long time ago
that I tried to learn it
now but but like your point I guess is
is just to say
languages that were different um
solidity to the concept of self and of
course you and I have exactly the same
problem talking to people who haven't
thought about this stuff because we have
to say well what I think illusionism is
the best theory well who's the thing
who's thinking in there no but to go
back to the point that you raised um
I'll give you an example of a problem I
face
regarding people people's very loose use
of words like mind Consciousness and
matter and other prejudices that are
unexamed uh and and go into that so
people don't even know what they're
thinking they don't know what
assumptions they're making so to give
you a concrete example I am often
faced with the falling so-called
refutation of idealism it goes as
follows well Bernardo you say you say
that everything is mental so everything
has to be efficacious insofar and it is
mental only mental states are causally
efficacious but I can give you an
example that it's not the case look if
you give me your arm and your arm and I
stick a needle in it that's a very
physical thing and you will move your
arm you will register paying and you
will move your arm or we don't need to
go that far what if I punch you in the
face or if you drink a bottle of wine
this very physical thing has a causal
effect on mental inner states Ergo
idealism is false
now you see the problem there for the
idealist there are no such things as
physical States outside mind all
material things are representations of
mental States so that needle going into
my arm is a dashboard representation of
a mental process interfering with
another across its dissociative boundary
that glass that bottle of wine that I
drink that's an icon on on my dashboard
that represents a transpersonal mental
state that I am bringing into my
dissociative boundary by ingesting it so
there is no
a bottle of wine as a material thing the
bottle wine the bottle of wine is a
representation of a mental state only
mental states are causal but it's very
difficult for people to make this switch
from dualism dualism seems to be so
bloody ingrained in language in our
logical assumptions in how we see
everything that people just even when
they think even when they agree with
idealism
over or ostensibly agree with idealism I
often see this in in courses I give that
even the idealists they fall for this
constantly so yeah that's an illusion
it's an illusion that there are no
mental States so from that perspective I
agree I am with you but I don't think
it's
I I don't want to keep on existing on
this but I prefer to to say specifically
what I mean like I just did yeah and to
just say illusionism yeah you see what I
mean yeah yeah
but you're making me think there
something quite uncomfortable so you've
got the let's say the drug that affects
the brain or the pin that goes in my arm
so the pin and the all those processes
are mental inequality and then hear me
out on this one I'm struggling to get it
clear but I'm then constantly asking
myself well why are the regularities
that are why does that does that happen
why are there as it were laws of nature
that make uh that you know the the
liquid run along there and all of those
things well then I realize
that as far as I know physics also can't
answer that question because if you ask
something like well why is Planck's
constant what it is or why is
um at the speed of light what it is I
don't think their answers are there
um so perhaps uh it's unfair to ask the
the um idealist uh to explain why the
mental properties of the world give rise
to or are
capable of trees and sky and all the
other things
the answer would be to be is to have
properties
whatever exists has properties
and therefore it behaves the way it does
because it is what it is instead of
something else
nature is what it is so it does what it
does it's not something else
the self that I could imagine that is uh
the author inside of these words and has
Free Will and all of that
would you say that it is what it is
because
okay I think nature is what it is and
the illusion of a personal self is a
behavior of nature
in other words it's a narrative behavior
of Nature and so I want to ask why it
throws up
this self all the time I mean in English
view you can sort of say well the the
system needs a representation of its own
capabilities and so it builds such a
representation and there it is and then
you can't say why it feels like anything
because materialism can't
um well does idealism really do better
on that
yeah you're asking pretty pretty
fundamental science uh philosophy of
science questions that they apply to any
metaphysics not only idealism I think
but uh but I'll try to answer
there is some use to the fiction of the
personal self you need to know to which
mouth to bring the fork
otherwise you starve so the the ego is a
useful tool
so hang on any animal will eat without
having I don't think that my cat has
much of a personal self but it is they
have a body schema too yeah indeed and
an attention schemer I imagine what they
don't have is matter cognition well now
metacognition is when the subject sort
of abstracts itself away from its own
experiential content
and that's why we say
I feel pain or I have hunger
because without metacognition we would
say I am pain I am hunger because the
being of the subject is its state and
the state of the subject is the
experience that it's quote undergoing so
the moment we say I have pain
or I will go there or I feel this way
that that's already a body schema with
metacognition on top so a metacognized
subjects separate from the rest of the
world is there a use to this I'm sure
there is a use to this so it's a it's a
very easy well I've put forward a
different Theory this I won't go into
now but Kurt probably knows something
about it that it's actually a product of
magnetic Evolution it's the force of
memes particularly words that get on
better when they're associated with the
I word and that our culture is
constantly um backing up this idea of
itself and making it bigger and bigger
and and more difficult to get rid of
says he wants to talk about some other
time I do feel that I understand a lot
better now so I rather enjoyed this
conversation even though I find it quite
stressful and difficult trying to get my
head around it and say something vaguely
intelligent in response
um but thank you very much for
foreign tremendous
advance in in understanding something
that you were not familiar with before
so could this to you for that I don't
know whether I would be able to make
this advance so quickly it took my ears
pardon it took me years of course of
course but then I've been worrying about
Consciousness for years so you know
that's why you said so many things that
sparked off things I've thought about
over all these many many years when I've
been obsessed with Consciousness
um I haven't thought about them in in
the exact way that you are but I've
thought about them enough at least to
recognize engage with it you know yeah
well
well thank you all I don't know if you
know us too but Bernardo knows that I
consider a theologian a success when I
could effectively have popcorn here and
just watch and watch yeah yeah because
it means that you both are from what I
saw trying to understand one another's
point of view rather than trying to
understand in order to debate you're
trying to understand because you're
curious so if I could summarize it went
something like initially Sue you're
saying look this is I'm an Illusionist
and then bernardo's saying well firstly
that's not what I understand illusionism
to be there are several others so that's
different secondly if what you're saying
is most of what we think of is the case
as not so in the same way that we think
that we model it well then is that not
trivial to the point of it being useless
then somewhat of an agreement there
maybe saying that well look most of the
world has that illusion and then Bernard
was like yeah but most of the academics
that we interact with don't like list me
one who studies philosophy who thinks in
the folk Manner and then it became much
of Bernardo explaining idealism so
that's my summary
to Susan she did specify more concretely
what is the illusion that she's talking
about it has to do with introspective
Illusions so that's narrow down things
quite a bit uh when she said that why
did you not want to use the word
introspection earlier sue you said it
was loaded
oh just because of
um the way when it happened in the early
20th century and or late 19th century
and people got to argue you know they
had to do these exercises of
introspecting on when they were looking
at a certain thing and then they'd argue
what they found and it became rather
useless and I suppose brought up in
Psychology and learning about that the
word in introspection has a has a bad
press but perhaps it doesn't that
doesn't apply to most people who hear
about introspection
um I mean all it means is looking within
now before that happened William James
was really good on the importance of
looking within and seeing what we there
find
um in his 1890 book for example
um but but uh behaviorism partly came
about because of the failure of
introspectionism and so we were landed
with a very restrictive behaviorism for
a long time in Psychology so that was
why but I don't think it's important
really I shouldn't have said that
Skinner's Black Box those were very dark
times yeah they were yeah like being
inside the Pacific box yeah
okay before you both get going the last
question I had well I guess it's the oh
second question I had is it's difficult
to ask Sue this because you don't Place
yourself in opposition to something
whereas Bernardo as far as I see from
you if you're in opposition to something
it would be materialism so let's just
take materialism what evidence or events
can occur that would make you reframe
your world view to the opposite side so
materialism like hypothetically what
could happen What could you see what
evidence would exist and sued the same
for you but it's difficult for me to
place yourself in opposition to say you
move to the other side so I don't know
well I can give you a different other
side YouTube because this comes up a lot
in my life if there were convincing
evidence of telepathy or of
um well let's stick stick with telepathy
um that was done with experiments with
adequate design and the statistics
properly done and with enough subjects
and so on so on uh and I became
convinced that telepathy was possible
then most of what I've thought about is
wrong in fact most of science is wrong
and you know the world changes
dramatically if that were the case but
but you're an automatic realist you said
it in the beginning
no no no I I it's not about materialism
it's about the way minds work
um because if there were telepathy then
most of the psychology experiments that
we do wouldn't work because you have to
have you know control conditions in
which people don't know what's going on
and then things like the placebo effect
would be completely
um changed because you could never
really be sure what people knew or
didn't know because they'd know they'd
know more than you think they know if
there was telepathy was possible it
would just ruin a whole lot of stuff
whether you're a materialist or not it
would have a dramatic effect on my
thinking about the nature of mind
couldn't it just increase the error bar
and not invalidate everything
uh
because I don't know uh it's difficult
to Think Through that's a that's a
perfectly reasonable question
um I think it the error bars will be so
huge that a whole lot of things would
just collapse
um but
I don't know I'm more optimistic than
you in this regard yeah you think you
think it might happen I I think no
process in nature is perfect
when it stops raining the ground doesn't
dry immediately when something Burns it
doesn't consume everything there is to
be combusted no processing nature is
perfect dissociation wouldn't be perfect
either especially under laboratory
conditions when you don't have that
emotional charge of real life
circumstances uh
um then you would be highly dissociated
but under normal circumstances there
could be
you know occasions in which the
dissociation becomes porous and I'm
saying this to you because I witnessed
one of these cases that I just cannot
dismiss
um but I don't think it would even
validate science because even if it can
happen it happens so rarely now and now
it's not even rare but the strength the
degree of the effect
is so tiny that's statistically speaking
I don't think it would invalidate
anything obviously we can't read each
other's minds all the time
obviously we don't know what's going on
in China all the time
right so even if there is some porosity
under emotionally charged circumstances
of normal life
they wouldn't apply on their laboratory
conditions anyway and that's why we
don't see it under laboratory conditions
so I wouldn't be worried at least
personally I'm not worried and I saw one
no I'm not saying I'm worried it would
be terribly exciting and I've said so
many times I would go back into
parapsychology if that happened I mean
the fact is there is no viable Theory
within parapsychology of how this could
work and if there were evidence that it
did work you could start to do
experimental work to test theories but
that just hasn't happened so that's what
makes me kind of well it's not
pessimistic pessimistic about the
possibility of being found
um but I don't think it's going to
happen but we shall see and if it did I
still maintain it would have dramatic
effects on our understanding of all
sorts of things
another idealism it would be nothing
extraordinary yes the dissociative
boundary yeah what did you witness
Bernardo what did you witness and was
one of those I was in a
sure no no it was not understand
I was on a on a holiday with my
girlfriend we were sort of out of
civilization for one week you know in
Germany she's from Germany and um and we
were already out of contact with family
and friends for one week one day she
wakes up in the morning I was already
awake when she woke up and she says I
had a strange dream I saw my grandmother
with her head wrapped up in in gauze
case gauze in a hospital with her two
daughters on on her side nothing was
moving nothing was happening but they
could pick up from her thoughts that she
was okay
and then I was playing with interpreting
her dreams from a union perspective for
a while we were playing that game and
when she told me that I thought this
this is highly unusual and something
came into me and I said call your father
so she called her father and her
grandmother had three children two women
and her father
and her father was at home picked up the
phone and said well good that you're
calling because in the middle of the
night no two or three hours ago before
she had woken up her grandmother had had
a brain stroke and was in the hospital
with her two daughters but the doctor
said although she couldn't speak yet the
doctor said she's not on their life on
the risk of life anymore and I thought
this is unprompted
so bloody specific that I thought okay
this happens it's all right I can
live with it and I'm not abandoning
science either
oh dear well I won't go through all my
usual reasons why those things happen
and how never mind now I know you got to
get going Sue but briefly I didn't get
bernardo's answer to that question of
what would cause him to reconsider or
not reconsider but actually move and
we're going to get to that but you
mentioned that you didn't see any
evidence and you know that there's
parapsychologists like Dean Rayden and
Julia
right and Daryl bem and I believe
Jeffrey mishlov is a cataloger rather
than a researcher but I could be
mistaken about that and Rupert sheldrake
so what do you make of their research
please uh this has to be for another
time uh it's there's so much to say and
I I'm tired now and I I really don't
want to have to do that fairly would be
very complex and it would involve a lot
of devious things that have gone on and
things I've discovered along the way and
it's another story okay but the point is
you've gone through their research and
it's not that you haven't seen them oh
God yes a lot not recently because I
gave up I really gave up doing
parapsychology around the turn of the
century and up until that time I would
have said that I was pretty much an
expert on the the literature that I you
know because I was really kept up with
it all since then I haven't so there may
have been things that have happened I
know vaguely about but to really examine
somebody's work and find out what was
going on takes a lot of effort arguably
it can take more time and effort than
doing the original research and I've
done a lot of that
um but it's a long story
okay and Bernardo for your answer
you're asking me to hypothesize about
evidence that would convince me of an
unnecessary and problematic hypothesis
so this is how I hear it so you
understand how I experience the question
it's like somebody who is telling me the
Flying Spaghetti Monster exists and it
it's the thing responsible for making
the planets go around their orbits with
its invisible noodly appendages reaching
out from a higher Dimension so Bernardo
what evidence would you need
to to or I would ask this person what
evidence do you need to discard the
Flying Spaghetti Monster hypothesis it's
like you know what do you have to come
up with materialism is explanatory
dissatisfying doesn't explain experience
in other words there is a sense in which
you explain it explains nothing because
all of our knowledge is conveyed by
experience materialism is internally
contradictory it replaces descriptions
for the thing described and then tries
to recover the thing described from the
descriptions I mean it's like a dog
chasing its own tail at light speed and
hoping to catch it one day it is um
empirically inadequate and Nobel Prize
last year went to experiments that show
that physical entities do not have
Standalone existence unless you believe
in some science fiction stuff like
parallel universes popping out every
fraction of a second for no reason or if
you believe in the magical hidden
variables of super determinism that are
not even described enough for us to be
able to say what they they are supposed
to be they are defined in terms of what
they need to do for us to rescue
materialism from that so it's so
overwhelming the K is against it is so
overwhelming that if you and I know it's
a dissatisfactory answer but if you ask
me what would make you change your mind
it's like well I would need to be a
child again that's what it would take I
would need to not have the knowledge and
the understanding that I have today uh
because it's a purial hypo vertices and
it was from the beginning the difference
is that people knew in the beginning it
was a pure Royal hypothesis and they did
it anyway because it was a a weapon
against the church by the way the needy
the horizontal record one of the authors
of lion cyclopedia the founding document
of the Enlightenment his own record
saying materialism doesn't work but we
need to keep on using it as a weapon
against the church but at some point mid
19th century because of the you know the
the Bourgeois Revolution led by Darvin
and others we forgot that because we
wanted the intellectual Elite to have
not not only to survive the church but
to have a domain over the church as far
as the culture is concerned and then it
went sideways but to me it's like I
can't answer this question I would have
to unlearn what I have learned over 48
years to to tell you something it's a
more formed hypothesis it's not even
wrong it's inconsistent it it's a
catastrophe so we if you ask me what
make what would change my mind
about the Multiverse hypothesis that I
could tell you I could tell you about if
we had an event with Statistics behind
it at CERN
um in which the energy footprint exceeds
what we can account for under a Quantum
field Theory
then I would say okay there is a leakage
across dimensions and I would take that
hypothesis more seriously but if you ask
me what would make me take materialism
seriously it's like asking me what would
what would it take for me to take the
Flying Spaghetti Monster seriously I
don't know the Flying Spaghetti Monster
would have to show up in front of me
no oh I haven't on Heaven and Hell
what what could convince me that the
seven or Hell well near-death
experiences certainly won't yeah so yeah
sorry sorry it's a dissatisfying the
answer
all right thank you all thank you all so
much and thank you for coming on thank
you for coming on for your seventh or
eighth time Bernardo and thank you for
your premiere on toll Susan and
hopefully it's not your last time
hopefully we do a one-on-one as well
it's been a pleasure
thank you the podcast is now concluded
thank you for watching if you haven't
subscribed or clicked on that like
button now would be a great time to do
so as each subscribe and like helps
YouTube push this content to more people
you should also know that there's a
remarkably active Discord and subreddit
for theories of everything where people
explicate tolls disagree respectfully
about theories and build as a community
our own toes links to both are in the
description also I recently found out
that external links count plenty toward
the algorithm which means that when you
share on Twitter on Facebook on Reddit
Etc it shows YouTube that people are
talking about this outside of YouTube
which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well if you'd
like to support more conversations like
this then do consider visiting
theoriesofeverything.org again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on toe full time you
get early access to ad-free audio
episodes there as well every dollar
helps far more than you may think either
way you're viewership is generosity
enough thank you